levon needs to make this decision he has
to capture that white pawn that's just
moved you cannot allow it to continue
marching up the board it will just
become
too strong and you'll have to keep an
eye on it forever so right now
black has to take off that pawn he does
white has a choice now white can take
that pawn or he can go the other way
with this king he goes the other way
with this game
a nice nice move by
magnus so the king has just activated
itself
as uh potentially attacking a pawn but
mainly it's
all are going to be about uh winning
pawns and at the same time
issuing threats to the black king yeah
exactly
black's king very very shaky stuck right
now yup
and potentially going to be eyed up by
the white rook as well so
yeah a lot of black pawns are going to
drop off temporarily black is actually a
pawn up
which is a bit surprising considering
just two three moves ago magnus could
have gone
pawn up for seemingly nothing so right
now black is a pawn up but
a lot of his pawns are gonna drop and
okay he decides you can't defend all of
those pawns
white uh the black rook needs to get
active first and there we go
the first pawn drops magnus carson
regaining a pawn there material parity
and
another one bites the dust another pawn
that drops off there white's king
snacking on the pawn
uh lavon he's distracted away the white
king and that black pawns
are going active that that's a runner
that's a pass pawn yeah the only
possible
in the position actually is that black
pawn so white's rook is going to have to
get distracted you have to control those
past pawns you always have to keep an
eye on them
and uh okay so what is uh
magnus going to do perhaps just start
advancing one of his own pawns
and no first he goes after that black
pawn he decided that was the most
urgent okay priority you surprised you
banker
slightly surprised because uh wha if i
were black i would just simply go rook
takes pawn
but the one going under the minute on
the clock here
yeah and that's going to be worrying
because now it is pure calculation
it is a little bit of pressure to deal
with maybe you can hold it with accurate
play but one slip
one's just going to be a pawn up maybe
even two points up for nothing so
yeah that clock situation is worrying
for levon okay rook takes pawn on the
board and magnus
instantaneously playing rook takes pawn
and uh one move that i was considering
here
is actually to step the rook one square
forward just to attack the
corner oh look at that reading his mind
levon plays it
and the idea is that um if white tries
to
white has two options why can either
push the pawn as magnus has done
or maybe use the rook to defend it but
that moving the rook to pass the square
would not have been advisable
and uh now black offers the rook
straight white could not add
well maybe what could have done but
white did not want to trade off those
rooks because it would have helped black
create a passport of his own and king of
porn games that porn would have run
through
would have promoted before white's pawns
and instead magnus keeping the rooks on
the board
so both sides are a bit stuck here
what's black's next move that's the
question you kind of don't want to move
anything
in a way right i mean you don't really
want to be moving your king
one step backwards because suddenly
you're gonna give white the opportunity
once the rook trade happens to push the
most
left most pawn with check
okay so big decision here i think magnus
will just shuffle his king to the side
um okay the evaluation bar really not
liking black's last move
let's try and work out the consequences
um i think the king moves
king moves across and maybe black just
giving ground with his king
i don't think he needed to do that the
black king was needed maybe uh where it
was to stop the white king stepping
forward later and
levon aronian shaking his head there
quite aggressively he knows that now
he's had to give way white was actually
threatening to trade rooks there and
then the white king would have brought
itself back down over
to the left side of the board so no more
rook trades white's a pawn up you cannot
allow the trade of ruxin
okay stockfish the computers suggest
pushing white central pawn
that's not easy that's not obvious yes
you create a pass pawn of your own
but the more porn trades happen the more
likely we are to head towards a draw
rook games are so tricky to evaluate
because even being down one point often
you can hold a draw comfortably
uh so right now i'm not 100 sure about
the stockfish
suggestion maybe it's very very good but
it is taking a bit more risk as well
it's narrowing the margin for error for
magnus carson so
he could just keep the attention but no
he goes for it he sees at the moment
gonna he's gone for it and
uh okay great move by magnus and
according to stockfish she has excellent
chances to win
but uh okay this is according to
stockfish this is with perfect computer
play
yeah sometimes on the board yeah
sometimes though the computers we
shouldn't look too much at them because
it might say plus two but it might be a
fortress or it might be a draw okay well
hang on a second because between 25
seconds left on the clock
levonoronian just moved his king and uh
i don't know
landed now next move it's check now it's
a discover check and once black's king
moves
white's rook's just going to step up one
square it's about to win black's pawn
level around he's shaking his head he's
just lost a second pawn two pawns
you won't be able to save the game one
point down maybe he had some chances but
magnus
working to end game magic again time
after time he's doing this it's
impressive yeah and uh you can see lavon
shaking his head he knows that he's
lat and any chances were draw strips i
just want to mention our tamiya also in
big big trouble the bar loving it for
ding and the
bloody sovereignty have 30 seconds left
on the clock drama in that one as well
what's happening here
yep this one is simply two pawns up and
the problem for black is he won't be
able to deal with both of them
yes he can deal with one pawn but uh the
two pawns would
stretch black's army to the maximum and
one pawn will occupy the black king one
pawn will occupy the black rook and at
the right time white king is maybe going
to go over
to the other side of the board and cost
black his rook
so white's king's going to go over to
support the other pawn with this last
move magnus is getting
getting ready really nice uh idea
actually he's getting ready he's going
to step his rook down one square most
likely
and then he's just going to protect both
of his pawns with one rook okay
he does the same idea but up of rank so
that's even more
uh well that's even stronger yeah and
now it comes and here you go the white
rook's on the perfect square
beautiful defensive play and now the
white king is free to run across
and assist the pawn on the left okay so
now
the king is going to start as much
there's nothing to stop it
yeah exactly why is he given a check
does he want more let's trust him i
think his end-game skills are
just i mean exemplary right now but
you're right he didn't need to give the
check he could have just walked over
with the king right
that would have done the job equally
well yeah so white
he's going to use the same strategy but
with his rook now on the sixth rank
earlier he started on the fifth now he's
moving up to the sixth point carefully
moves downwards it doesn't move up and
now white is simply going to push
those two pawns move it up one square
forward
and uh there's just nothing to stop the
white king
marching over to the left and assisting
that pawn in its promotion
and uh look at that dingley ran he has
won the second game
against vladislav artemyev so that means
he is up by one point
in their semi-final match and magnus
carlsen is about to tie this match then
yes yeah those pawns uh well it's
inevitable now those pawns are marching
forward one of them is going to become a
queen
or at least cost black his rook so
black's king stuck look at this magnus
paralyzing the black king with his pawn
there and the white king is yeah ready
to run over
is there any chance for any stalemates
because we saw wesley was quite
some really sneaky stalemate
unfortunately i don't think there will
be because black's king is always going
to have squares to run to
as long as you don't trap the opponent's
king allowing you uh allowing
black to give up a rook and there you
can see this one no style mates here
so white's king this is very slow
progress but it's
sure progress yes
you know slayer steady will win the race
absolutely guaranteed and now the king
as fast as it can will march its way
okay there you go
kings are slow pieces is only moving one
square across so he's going to move one
square
to the right oh okay the rook moves
it's the same idea yeah there's no rush
just keep
everything protected white's rook doing
a great job and levon aronian resigns he
knows that he cannot
save this end game any longer it's over
magnus carlsen is able to tie the
semi-final match against uh
levon aronia and they have now won one
game each both with
the white pieces and